the square root of 2 is an irrational
number so how do we plot it on the
number line let's see to understand this
concept having the knowledge of the
pythagoras theorem is very important let
us take side a b
now we draw a perpendicular from it side
bc
both of one unit each here we will
obtain the length of ac as square root
of two with the help of this concept we
can easily draw square root of two on
the number line
this is a number line we take this
distance as one unit as well as this
distance as one unit now the length of
this segment will be the square root of
two with the help of a compass we draw
the same length on the number line and
we will obtain the total length as
square root of two similarly can you
tell us how we can draw the square root
of 3 on the number line we shall look at
this answer in our next video